all right time to get started thanks for
staying until the very end
this is my slide or sort of is it looks
very much like a slide so what I want to
do in this hour and I guess that's why
they put me in the last slot because
they're expecting higher I'll overrun by
three hours is to write your own Excel
365 so what I want to do is to show you
a couple of nice things in F sharp that
will lead us to implement something like
a very simple spreadsheet that runs in
the web browser and I'll show you some
nice I've sharp patterns and some nice F
sharp tools so here I'm in Visual Studio
code and I do have lots of to do here to
start with and the first thing I need to
do for my excel is to actually sort of
represent some state of a spreadsheet so
if you have a spreadsheet what what
stage does it have
so spreadsheet has some columns and I'll
have my columns will be just ABC da da
da so I'll remember what columns I have
in my spreadsheet I'll have some rows
these will be numbers and on so I'm
using character and int as a position so
I'll define type for this because it
will be easier so my position is
something like a 5 so that's a character
and an int and then the other thing I
will have in my state is what's the
active cell so if you click somewhere in
a spreadsheet that's the active cell the
one you get to edit you might not have
any so this will be optional so active
cell is position option and then I'll
have the content of my spreadsheet and
this will be a map from positions to
strings so yeah yeah I got typos here
I'll fix this
and so my cells will be for some
positions in my spreadsheet I will have
a string which is what you typed in
there now when I start the spreadsheet
so this is one of those two three
snippets that I don't want to type
because they're boring so initially I
will start with rows from 1 to 15 and
you could add more calls from a to K and
you could add more nothing active and no
no entry so this is the setup for my
spreadsheet and what I want to do now is
just actually start building it so here
I'm using and I'll say more about this
I'm using the Elm style functional
reactive architecture and this comes
with this function called app that
starts the application you give it a def
ID the initial state and then we need to
give it these two functions and I'll
tell you more about what they actually
do so you can ignore this for now and in
render will just say text hello and DC
and then update that's the one I will
explain later I'll just say given a
state and an event return state so
nothing this rendering bit this is
you're using a little DSL to build HTML
and if I save it I have a process
running in the background that
principles of stuff to the console and I
have a browser running here where my
application will show now I'm using
really nice really nice setup in Fable
where whenever I save things they will
get automatically updated so that's what
I that's what I want to do all right
is this a spreadsheet yet no we can't
sell it so we have to do more work so
the first thing I need to do in the
rendering is to actually render this the
the the spreadsheet properly so I'm
going to create a table now the first
square brackets that's the CSS
attributes or the sort of attributes on
the tag the second is the contents so we
will have to
with first throw and in the first row we
will generate one empty cell because
that's the left upper corner and then
for every column in my columns
I will generate heading where the text
inside is this column so I'm using two
things here one is that I have this
state argument and that represents my
current state of a spreadsheet and so I
can get stuff from it the other thing
I'm using this yield keyword and absorb
inside square brackets which is a really
nice way to work with lists because you
can just generate lists kind of like
yield return in c-sharp and here it
works quite nicely for generating HTML
as well based on some data so we've got
one row now we need even more rows so
I'll iterate over all the rows and for
every row we will generate a row what
will be in the row the first thing will
be the the text with the row number so
this is my row and then I'll have and
now I'm getting tired I'll do copy/paste
for every column in the row we will need
to render the cell now what do we need
to pass through the cell I'll explain
what rigorous in a short while we need
to tell it where we are so the position
is my column and my row and we'll also
give it the state and I'll do more work
here in render cell so we get position
and state and right now just to test
what what I've actually done we'll say
text dot dot dot and render is done
render cell will need more work and
let's see what we've got
looks like a spreadsheet yay now you
can't edit it which is kind of kind of
sad
I also I think my spreadsheet is a bit
missile I
so what did I mess up I forgot the yield
keyword it was actually giving me a red
green squiggly to tell me I'm wrong but
I was ignoring it so now we've got a
nice grid what do we need to do now so
now I want to show you my second slide -
doo doo doo doo
so my second slide is actually
explaining this Elm style so this is a
really sort of nice nice programming
pattern where you compose user
interfaces just by defining these things
so you need to define type representing
your state and that's the state of my
spreadsheet so I've done that already
then you need to define an event so this
is basically what possible things can
happen in your spreadsheet it can be
click to select a cell and it can be
entered to update the cell and then you
define an initial state and a function
that ignore this units event bit
function that takes the state and
produces HTML so you have a state you
can render spreadsheet we've just wrote
that part and you need to write an
update function that given an state and
an event produces a new state so if
something happens you will calculate a
new state and then it will automatically
call render to re-render the page and
the reason why this works and why it's
not stupid is that the update of the
page actually uses different algorithm
to figure out what's the minimal changes
that actually need to happen in the
browser and that it only does those so
it doesn't replace the whole page that's
a really clever trick and we can now use
it to add a bit of interactivity to my
spreadsheet and I'm going to move my
cheat sheet up here so that I don't get
lost so the first thing I need to do is
to define the event so I have my state
what can be my event what can happen
so I want two things I won't start at it
so this is when you click on a cell and
you want to edit that cell and this will
carry a position so we know what we want
to edit and when we click on it we
change the state so that this is the
selected cell and we want update value
which happens whenever you do some
typing in the in the selected cell so
that we will have position and the new
value and we want to update update our
state to reflect this and now we need to
go back to rendering and do something
clever here so I'll have whenever I have
cell I need to have two different cases
one is when there is an editor then I'll
create an input and the other when there
is just the value and then I will
evaluate the value and render it so I do
have a basic template here because I'm
too lazy to write this so render editor
creates a TD element with an input with
some stuff it's just an input element
and render view just does this TD with a
value and in render cell I need to make
a decision so if the what did I call it
active active if the active cell is the
current position then what I'm going to
do is call a render editor and what does
render editor take it takes trigger
function takes the position and takes
the state now it takes a value and value
I don't have yet so I'll need to do that
otherwise we will call render view with
all those things now we don't have a
value so we need to get a value to get
the value I will look at my state
because my state has this map or
dictionary of its cells and here I can
do math dot try find give
to look up key and and the map and it
will try to find the cell now this can
be optional so what I'm going to do is
just say default value and if it doesn't
exist we won't we will use an empty
string it needs to be default art I got
the name wrong
so I'm calling a built-in function that
will replace nuns with with empty string
so if I render my page now well that's a
bit less impressive all my dots are gone
but I haven't done the clicking yet so
how do we do the clicking when we render
a view in the attributes we can say
things like what I've done here above
with the ID arrow cell add that just
says assign this value to this attribute
but I can also do on click and here I
define this this nasty operator which
says assign an event handler to this to
this event and an event handler is a
function that will takes the element
that this happened on we can ignore that
and now the clever thing is that we can
say when the old click event happens
trigger the start edit event and this
tells my Elm style run time that
something has happened it needs to call
the update function response to this
event and re-render the page so I just
need to say trigger this and it will all
audible all happen the only other thing
I need to do is to go at to the end to
my update function and say this is a
function that does pattern matching and
if the command is start at it at this
position then we return a new state
where we replace the active cell with
some position now I get a green warning
here because I'm not handling
the update value that's one of the nice
things in EPS our pattern matching I'll
fix that later
and let's see if I can click around and
add it cells so I can click around type
something in here
it never gets stored because I haven't
implemented that part yet but at least I
can click around and type numbers so
that's a good start
and to do the other part so this is
again one snippet that I'm just going to
copy because it's a bit longer I need to
go to my input in my editor and add this
command which says own input trigger an
update value event with this position
and what I'm doing here is that I'm
dynamically accessing the value of the
input that the person is typing in so
the D parameter of this function that's
going to be the HTML input element and I
can do not turn or it's some it's some
sort of event event object from
JavaScript so it's JavaScript that's why
it's so ugly I just do dot target dot
value to get the value and I have a
value and I can trigger my nice update
value event and now I need to go back to
my update function and actually
implement this so if I get update value
for a position here's my new value then
what do I need to do well I need to
calculate new cells so state dot cells
is my map with the with the value
assignments and I can do map dot add to
say at this position at this value and
this is a new map with with representing
the new updated cells and will return a
new state with new cells now the nice
thing here that this is this is all
purely functional
generating a new state so if I had any
other reference to the state doing some
other work in the background I wouldn't
just override the state now so let's see
what happens if I save this I saved it
I can type 1 T 3 here 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and
then go back change it I can type equals
1 plus 4 and nothing happens so we've
got a spreadsheet where you can edit a
table now this took me 16 minutes
exactly so that's a good start we have
some user interface now we actually need
to do spreadsheet that does something
you can sell so let's let's improve my
spreadsheet so the next thing we need to
do in my spreadsheet is use is to do
some parsing when you type a formula and
we actually need to parse the formula
and then evaluate it and to do this I'm
going to use a very very minimal parser
Combinator library all the code will be
will be somewhere on github after the
taco I'll tweet a link you can have a
look at it so this is a site from the
elvish style this is the only thing that
I'm not going to implement from scratch
during the talk that was maybe we should
have done this with Scott blushing where
he would write the parser Combinator in
an hour and I would do this the nice
thing here is that you just have a type
called parser and then you can compose
these parsers now a parser is something
that takes a list of characters and it
can fail and produce none or it can
succeed and produce some containing a
pair with the parsed value and the rest
of the characters that it didn't need
so if you run a parser it might tell you
if you have a string 1 2 3 + 4 it can
tell you I parse the number here's 1 2 3
it's an end and the rest is +4 parse
that next and then there's a bunch of
combinators for working with parsers the
the or one says try the first part
sir if it doesn't work try the second
one and return whichever succeeded and
the star says parts the first thing then
parts the second thing and give me both
so these are my parser combinators and
now I need to define what the what the
formulas look like and actually
implement those so I'm going to put that
put my hints here and I need to define
what is an expression so this will go to
my domain model and my expression so you
can type a number which is just an int
she say 42 or you can define a binary
operation which has an expression and
operator and another expression so this
is really nice way of expressing what
what what an equation is and what will
add more stuff to this later and now I
need to write some parsers so what is an
operator an operator can be one of those
well-known characters so I'll I'll do
some nice copy and pasting here it can
be x plus there's more - and divide so
this just says recognize any of these
special characters
now number so my parser Combinator
library has a has conveniently a parser
for integers which says parser of int so
it will recognize and end the other
thing that my parser Combinator library
has is that it comes with this map
function where I can say given and power
a parser so so let's see if I do string
of n then what this means is it says
given a parser that recognizes integers
whatever they parse
transform it using this function so here
I just converted the string and I get a
parser that will recognize strings now
what I want is a parser that will
recognize my expressions so I can say
number and and now I've got a parser
that will recognize an expression which
happens to be an integer now I can use
nice features of F sharp and just say
this is an integer math number so I can
parse numbers that's a good start now I
need to parse binary things so a binary
thing let's starts up with something
simple it's going to be a number
followed by an operator followed by
another number this doesn't do nest it
things that's alright we'll add that
later and now we have a parser that
recognizes a pair with a pair of
expression and character and another
expression so this is three things
they're bracketed as pair of pairs
because the operator just gets sort of
associated to the left so but we have we
have all the three things we need and we
can turn them into a binary operation
using map where I get the left thing and
the operator and then the right thing
and I'll say binary left op right all
right so this is this is probably
something forgotten that's what did I do
binary no this is right let's see if I
save it then it magically works all
right
the demo gods are with me so far that's
nice so now I'll have an expression so
an expression can be a binary thing or a
number and let's see if this works so
I've written too much code without
running it so I'm feeling kind of
nervous
so what I want to do now is to go to my
view and go to my render cell and
whenever I'm rendering that the the view
with the value I actually wanted to try
evaluating it or try parsing it so what
I'm going to do is say well if I don't
have a value if there is none no value
then I'm just going to say return render
empty string if there is some value then
let's try parsing it so let's say expert
and the parser a library comes with this
run function which will run so I'll say
parsed run the parser so run takes a
parser a sequence of characters and
returns a option because the parser
might fail so parse is my parse
expression or none so what I'm going to
do you just to see what happened
it's just convert this whole thing to
string and say string parsed which is
not the real thing yet but a good start
you see what's what's going on so now if
I say 5 then I get number 5 so it
actually sort of formats the FS or data
type as something that looks like absorb
if I say 5 plus 4 that's not 4 this is 4
then I get binary of number 5 plus
number 4 so this is this is all I
implemented so far and it seems to be
working if I type I'd although ABC then
it says null that's just because I like
to prove the C sharp people wrong and
Matz was saying in the morning that F
sharp has all this null thing sorted you
can get now if you try hard here I'm
getting null because that's how fable
actually at runtime represents non-event
the none value so it's sort of hidden
from the F sharp code but Italy still
leaks through the JavaScript which
actually is
of nice because it means when you get an
object from JavaScript you can just
pattern match it and say none some and
handle it so this means the parser has
failed so now we've got a parser that
sort of works and we want to do some
more things so the nice thing that I
think is sort of really really elegant
here with this example is using the
observed discriminated type
discriminated union type to represent
your expressions so an expression can be
a number or a binary expression we will
add reference as well when you say like
a 1 plus 4 and this is a recursive type
because the binary itself contains more
expressions so you can say sort of if
you say 1 plus 4 times 7 then that's
going to be binary of number and another
binary and they're not only sort of nice
readable thing but they're also very
easy to process because we can just
write a function that will pattern match
on this and handle all the cases and do
whatever you need to do to evaluate so I
want to write the evaluator now and for
that I need to copy my next chunk of
cheats so I want to add a recursive
evaluator I'm going to put it somewhere
here just after my parser so to write an
evaluator I'm going to define a function
called evaluate that takes an expression
and pattern matches on it which I'm
writing using this function function
construct which is just like take an
argument pattern match on it and when
it's a number n then my result will be
the number so this was really hard when
it's binary we get
operator and right and this is where we
need to do a bit more work so the thing
on the left and right
they're both expressions themselves so
we will need to evaluate those
expressions and to make that possible I
need to mark this function as recursive
and then I can say left evaluated is
evaluate L let right evaluate it is
evaluate R so now I've evaluated left
and right and now I need to do the
operator now to do that I'm going to use
a bit from the cheat sheet so what I'm
doing here is just defining a mapping a
dictionary where you can look up using
the operator character and it will give
you the actual F sharp function or the F
sharp operator to do the plus minus
times and so on so then I can say
operators dot lookup index using the
operator and this is a function that
takes two integers and I think I'm
missing a here oh I can't spell at all
that's right so fortunately I'm in a
type typed language so I don't have to
learn how to spell so now the binary
also evaluates and we need to actually
call evaluate here when I parse things
so once I parse things now this is this
is still an option we'll fix error
handling later on so now I'm going to be
very nasty and just say dot value which
will throw an exception if the value
isn't there don't do this well do it do
it but then remove it so now I can say
evaluate this and this is my result and
I still can't spell and my result is an
int so converted to string and display
it
now if it reloads and if I don't make
any any spelling mistakes while typing
my equations I should be able to say 1
plus 2 or 4 times 728 all looking good
or even just 42 that should still work
as well so now I can evaluate really
basic equations and there's two things I
want to do next one thing I want to do
is to actually fix my parser to do
nested nested things too so to do that
I'm not going to type all of it I'll
just paste it in and give you a sketch
of or
explain what it what it means so the one
tricky thing here is that now an
expression can actually be inside an
expression and I'll add some new lines
so that you can see the whole thing so
here I'm defining an expression but I'm
not saying what it is yet so I'm saying
well I'll have some expression but I'll
I'll define what it means in a second
then I say a bracketed thing is an
expression with some spaces and some
brackets around a term which is a sort
of closed expression as a number or a
bracketed expression a binary is a term
followed by space followed by operator
followed by some more space and followed
by one more term and we wrap it in the
binary so this is the same thing I was
doing before but now with terms and
spaces and then I say an expression is
now a binary or a term and then I say
this is actually expression and I also
add a formula which is equals expression
and an equation you can put in
spreadsheet which is space formula
our number and space so the whole
business with expressions I'm doing that
before because I'm defining an
expression as binary or term term could
be bracketed and bracketed contains an
expression so I need expression to
define what is an expression and for
that you need to do some recursive
recursive tricks so I've defined
recursive expressions and now I'm going
to change my evaluation my play parser
here to actually use that I call it
equation or did I call it formula
equation is the one with which could be
either formula with equals or just a
number so this is an equation and if I
save it and look at what I've got then
now I can just put in numbers like I was
doing before so I can have some numbers
and then I can say equals five times
seven plus two which is 45 does that
sound right probably yeah mathematics is
difficult yeah I think this is right
so this seems to be working we can
evaluate equations we're still missing
the most important thing which is to be
able to say something like a one plus
four if I do it it just crashes I get
some JavaScript error here so we need to
fix this and to do this I need to add a
new thing to my expression and that will
be a reference so if I go back to my
domain model then I can say an
expression can be a number or binary or
a reference of position and
if my if my editor was a bit bigger you
could see on the right panel it tells me
where am I missing some case there's
this little green dot that's telling me
you added with reference to your
expression but you haven't implemented
the handling of references yet so we'll
fix that in a second I also need to add
references to my parser so if I say what
is reference my reference is something
like a five so that's a letter followed
by an integer and I'm going to just say
map reference because the thing on the
Left
produces a parser that recognizes a pair
with a character and an int and this
thing takes a position which is
character and then and so now I have a
parser that recognized one more kind of
expression specifically dereference and
I can add it as another case to my term
which is the sort of basic syntactic
constructs so now a term is a number or
bracketed thing or reference and so now
I can actually parse references and
here's the missing bit where I haven't
implemented the evaluator yet so here we
have evaluator for numbers and for
binary and we need to add handling for
references so what's a reference it has
a position ah no no no let me see
yes you are right typing is so hard I
don't know how you people managed to do
it all day so we need to evaluate
references now this is this is difficult
because this is just some position but
we don't really have the cells available
here we just have the expression so
we'll need to tweak our evaluate
function to actually get all the cells
from the spreadsheet because it might
need to do
cup into the spreadsheet now if I do
this then I need to pass the cells
through all the recursive calls so
that's one thing the other thing is I
will actually need to go to my evaluate
function which is somewhere somewhere up
here no I need to go to the place where
I call the evaluate function in render
cell and give it the cells from my from
my spreadsheet state so now we have
access to all those all those cells and
if we want to evaluate a reference that
we need to find the value for the cell
so this is the the code that the person
wrote and you can see I'm using map dot
find which will just throw if the if the
cell doesn't contain anything so this is
one more place where I'm doing things in
a dangerous way and that's something
I'll have to fix later then we will run
our equation parser on this code so this
is parsed and again this is option and
I'll have to do the parsing I'll have to
have to do the error checking here
eventually
but if we just pretend it it will always
work then I can say parse dot value this
is dangerous we'll remove it later and
save my code and let's see if it works
so if I put say 3 in a cell c3 then I
can go here and say c3 plus 1 that's 4 D
4 times 2 that's 8 so it seems to be
working fine and if he did if he did
spend a lot of time you could we
we're now good enough that we can almost
implement a Fibonacci numbers so this is
f3 plus f4 I don't have the drag down
feature yet so I'll just have to have to
type all of those manually looks good
doesn't it I'll do one more and then
I'll stop all right
that's just my Fibonacci number
calculator implemented in my own
spreadsheets now one interesting thing
you can do here is you can say equals
let's see I'll go here so I can do
equals I don't know f1 now as you can
see I got some JavaScript error which is
why it stopped working
it says key not found so that's not very
good or I can just say 1 modulo 5 and I
don't have that implemented so I have
option has no value so my error handling
is kind of poor so that's the next
that's the next step for my spreadsheet
I think I implemented everything I
wanted here yep so now it's time to do
some error handling and how do you do
error handling in F sharp bay might be
one answer but I've got the better one
which is Rob so if you want to do error
handling in F sharp you can I actually
so a sort of word of warning you can use
exceptions in F sharp and very often
they're actually really nice way to
handle exceptions because F sharp has
has try-catch support and it also works
in works inside asynchronous workflows
and so if you're if you're doing sort of
handling of unexpected exceptions then
you can just use exceptions and it's
going to be easier
most very often but here we sort of want
to explicitly say this may be missing so
we're going to change our evaluator so
that it returns option and option is the
F sharp F sharp answer to this sort of
null problem that Matz mentioned in the
beginning so an option could be none
meaning there is no value or sum and
then we have the value and the F sharp
library comes with two useful functions
one of them is option dot map which says
if I have an option of T and a function
that can turn T's into hours then I can
produce an option of R and the other one
says if I've got an option of T and I
have some more work to do that can also
fail that might produce our option then
I can sort of unwrap all those options
and just give you an option of our so
the first one basically says transform a
value if it worked the second one says
get something that might have failed do
some more work that can fail as well and
return just a simple value that is
either there or not there so we'll need
to use those along the way and to do
that I'm going to go here in my
recursive evaluator and change this so
that rather than returning an int it
returns an option of and so this case
was easy if we have a number we just
return some number and now we basically
have to go and fix all the errors until
the compiler is happy
so here the compiler is complaining
because these things are in options so
rather than just using the
value I can say option dot bind and if
we actually got successfully evaluated
the left thing that we can continue try
evaluate the right thing and if this
worked as well that we can do a map
operation that will run the operator so
now I've got I've got the transformation
working here this returns an option I've
also got a bunch of things that can fail
in reference so this should really be
try find to handle the case that you're
referencing something that doesn't have
a value if this works that we get code
and then we can run the parser and if
that worked as well then we get the
parse expression and only then we can
actually evaluate it and if the
evaluation still fails well we return
none and bind will take care of care of
that so I've changed the evaluate
function and if I go to the place where
I'm actually calling it down here in my
rendering now this is something that can
fail and now I can also fix the thing
where previously I said let's just parse
it assume it worked so let's let's be a
bit nicer and let's run the parser and
then say if this worked then we will
continue we get the parsed value and we
try evaluating it and if this worked as
well then whatever result we get we will
just format it as string and this gives
us a result which is a string option now
I want to nicely format this
as well so I will change my render view
function and give us give it this whole
option value and here I'll just say some
empty and I'll go to render view now
this value may be optional so what I'm
going to do here is to say insert a
style if it's none then give it a red
background otherwise no special styling
and I'll add a default value default arc
where if it's if it failed then I will
display hash error to make it look like
excel all right because that's what my
boss one's saying so now I can say this
is this is this is 5 this is 11 this is
C 3 plus C 4 this worked but if I do c8
then I get an error if I do something
that doesn't parse I get an error if I
change this value to 0 then I actually
get an error over there so this is a
nice thing that works sort of
automatically for free because as its
updating the the view it will recompute
the the cells and so if I delete it it
the error will get propagated if I make
some changes here it all gets updated so
I've now got I now have a have a nice
error handling now there's still one
case that I'm not really handling well
so if I go to cell b2 and I say b2 plus
1 then what will happen the the famous
nothing
it seems broken happened in my
JavaScript I get
maxximum call stacks I succeeded
so my evaluator tried really hard called
itself a lot of time but haven't haven't
really done that yet what do we do about
that well this is this is actually one
thing that is now really really easy to
fix and by the way the the way the Excel
engine does it is that the the render
func the evaluate function just counts
until it gets called 100 times and then
it's as well probably no so we can
already already do something that's
better than Excel where as I'm doing the
evaluation I will keep a set of the
reference cells that I've already
visited and if I get to the cell again
then I'll say none so rather than just
counting to 100 we will we will actually
check that you either have a have a
cycle so I will add a new parameter
Refs which will be a set of the
references I already visited and
whenever I call myself recursively I
will have to propagate this information
so that's this part and when I'm in the
reference case so here then what I want
to do is to add this new cell that I've
just sort of got to to my set so I'll
say sets not add position to my
references and now I'm saying I saw this
I saw this I walk through this through
here if I ever go here again it's an
error and to handle that I can now do
something like pattern matching on on
the reference but with the when Clause
where I can't a test whether the set
contains this position and if that's the
case there
we have a reference to a cell that we
already had to visit while we were
evaluating so we say none this is an
error does not support it and now if I
go back it didn't it didn't refresh
because I get this red error mark here
on the side so I forgot one thing when I
call evaluate initially I obviously need
to give it empty set of things I haven't
I haven't seen any references yet so
that's what I have to do and now it
reloads and I can say see three plus one
and I get an error if I go back and
change it and you see two plus one then
now it works so that's my that's my
spreadsheet that's my spreadsheet done
and just to show you how sort of
complicated this whole thing is from a
bird's eye perspective if I delete all
the comments then I have some bit here
which is defining the domain model so
this is just saying what is actually a
spreadsheet
it has positions it has expressions that
you can put in the cells and have stay'd
which is what I need to render and it
has these two events which is the sort
of operations that can happen so here is
my domain model then I had second chunk
of code here which was implementing all
the different parsers so I can parse the
things you can type in your in your
spreadsheets most importantly equations
that are composed of expressions then I
had one more chunk of code which was
this recursive evaluate function so this
is a recursive one recursive function
that walks over the expression resolves
the references propagates errors
correctly
and checks for checks for recursive
references and then I have all the
rendering code here so render editor
render view render sell and the main
rendering function and the update
function I'll move a bit up so in my
rendering code that's that's a bit
longer because we just had to render
else of different elements and render
cell does the sort of clever thing of
figuring out is it the current one or is
it is it just the view in which case we
need to evaluate it and my main
rendering function and then I have the
update function which is handling the
events and saying if this happens this
is how we update the state and I've got
my entry point code which just says this
is the initial state and and start so if
I figure out how to turn on line numbers
I turned them off previously so that I'm
not destructed by this then it actually
fits in something like 130 lines of code
and that's implementing that's
implementing a spreadsheet that does not
everything that Excel does but still
quite a lot of quite a lot of clever
things already so there's there's sort
of one thing that I haven't done yet
that I wasn't really expecting to have
time for so I'll just show you tell you
what it would be if I did have longer
slot one thing that my my spreadsheet
was doing is that every time you render
it actually evaluates all those cells
and that's fine for a small one but it
wouldn't really work for something like
Excel where people can create too
abide Excel spreadsheets and run the
entire economy of the state using an
Excel spreadsheet or basically
everything so the way to do this better
would be to keep a dependency graph
where if I have a1 and c1 which are just
numbers and then I create a cell b3 that
reference
references these two cells then I would
actually build a graph that says I'm a
cell this is what I depend on now how
would you do that
a very simple sort of easy way to do
this sort of thing in F sharp is to
change my evaluator to construct not a
number not an evaluated result but a
representation of a cell which has two
things it has a way of getting the
current value and a way of notifying
when it has changed and then you when
you rerender you just update the update
numbers in the cells and they will say
have I changed not well then I'm not
going to trigger this observable but if
the number of changes then they can say
trigger this observable and all the
cells that depend on them will subscribe
to this notification and do the
recomputation so building a graph using
these things is the sort of last thing
that my spreadsheet is missing and that
would that would take sort of 15 more
minutes that I wasn't really expecting
to have so that's just a just a sort of
sketch of what you might need to do so
the one thing that I think I often sort
of get when people when people see me
write some code life is that you say
it's nice you can do all this in one
hour but is this really what ifs are
programming looks like in the real world
aren't you like you trimmed this down to
the very simple thing so that it fits in
a talk
and I did that I I did sort of simplify
this this a lot but this is really what
the FS are programming looks like in the
real world because when I need to write
some solve some problem most of my time
is often spent figuring out how to
actually best do this and obviously the
way to figure out how to best do things
is to use some crazy scaffolding engine
to generate 100 classes for me in 100
files and then modify one spent the rest
of the afternoon fixing my code base so
that it actually builds and then running
built and seeing that it didn't work no
so in in F sharp I think that the sort
of way of developing is that you really
very often start with something simple
and write a lot of code to explore
what's the best way to of doing it and
when that code as sort of 200 lines of
code or or maybe 400 lines of code then
you actually say well now it's a bit
long for one file and you split it and I
sort of sketched how this would look
like here because I do have a bit for
domain model that I would put in one
file I have a bed for parser that I
would put in another file I have an
evaluator another file I'll have the
rendering and maybe with update and
initial I would put it in the main file
and that's also a point where I would
actually start worrying about adding
some more tests because so far I just
tested everything interactively and
that's that's a way to get the quick
feedback that people often want from TDD
from sort of test runner a part of that
part of that is give me a quick feedback
here I get quick feedback in an in
another way but when I move to something
bigger that I would add some unit tests
make sure that it actually does keep
working so I start programming really
looks like this in the real world
and most of the time you're sort of
exploring ideas separately and then you
then you put it as part of your of your
bigger bigger thing so to wrap up I
wanted to do a talk that actually shows
you how you approach solving one
reasonably interesting problem like
writing a spreadsheet and along the way
I've used a couple of interesting things
first of all it was all running in the
browser using fable which is an amazing
absorb to JavaScript compiler with a lot
of lot of active people around in the
community this is part of the safe stack
which is sort of more more sort of a
library a set of libraries that really
do everything you need around web
development nicely connected and
documented together I use the Elm style
of programming with the sort of update
and render functions and I used it in a
very simple way but safe spec comes with
a elvish library which does it in a sort
of more proper way and I use the nice
features of sort of f-sharp
compositionality by doing the parsers
with with two custom operators to get
them composed in two directions and all
the way everywhere through my code I
used pipes for domain modeling and the
option type for error handling so before
I let you go I still have 48 seconds so
there is a functional track happening
here for the next two days with more
more talks on functional programming so
if that's your if that's your area then
do stay here or come or lots of other
good talks in the next few days
drag your friends in if they if they
somehow had to go to something else they
totally be here next time and we are
also running fpsb lab lunch meeting or
lunch hour it is in the program I don't
no in which room is it room 10
so come come to room 10 tomorrow and the
day after if you want to ask any
questions I will I will also be there
and lots of the other functional Trek
speakers will be there so we can we can
help you write some code and join the
functional functional crowd thank you
[Applause]